- It's always young
people that have,
that their frontal,
well, A, they have all of this
energy, all of this passion,
and they want to change
the world, right?
I mean, you talk
about young people
and always talking about
the want cultural change,
they want a revolution,
and they want to be part
of something bigger
than themselves.
A lot of the older
folks, I'm 50 now,
we have gray hair, which
is a sign of wisdom.
We've been around a while to see
that all this history stuff
is actually important.
And so when you're
young, you need a vision.
And so I think that
if we give the vision
as older wiser people
who understand that
ideas have consequences,
that history can teach us about
where we're headed
in the future,
that if they get on board with
that, and they're inspired,
if they catch the vision that's
rooted in the right stuff,
I think that that not only,
I don't think that it's they
who are going to
make the difference.
I'm banking on the power of
God working in their hearts
and through their minds
to make better decisions
than we've made in
this generation.
That's where my hope is.
(calm music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is an '80s sit-com
legend, a touring speaker,
bringing the gospel
across America,
and the host of the
"Campfire Revival"
on Facebook and Instagram.
Kirk, Cameron, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Hey, Dave, it's so good
to be talking with you.
I hope you don't
mind me bringing you
into my backyard like this.
I just thought it might
be a little different
for your program
and the viewers.
- Kirk, I believe this
is the first time,
in I don't know, man, how
many hundreds or thousands
of shows that I've done that
someone has done it outdoors
with a fire and
an American flag.
I've never been prouder.
- You know, I just feel like
we got to go grassroots.
We got to get real.
And it's just, this is as
real as it gets for me.
I got my tomato garden
off to the left.
I got a fire here, s'mores
in a couple of hours.
And you know, we're going to
play like "Born in the USA"
with the flag waving in the
breeze here pretty soon.
- Are you allowed to
have an American flag
just waving in the breeze
in crazy California?
I don't want to
out you my friend,
but you are in crazy
California, not too far from me.
- Well, I spend enough
time in Florida and Texas
and Tennessee to kind
of balance it out.
So, I love it out here though.
You know, it's a
beautiful state,
and it's my hope and my prayer
that good people
across this state
will begin to reclaim
the values that we want.
And we want to see them
represented in this state
and not abandon it.
- Alright, well, we're going
to get to some of those values,
we're going to get to
that flag behind you,
and we're going to get to
the campfire and all that.
But I got to start
at the beginning.
And the beginning, for
us, is the eighties.
You were on ""Growing Pains."
It was like the number one show
for a couple of years at least.
How many seasons
was it on total?
- I believe we were on six
or seven seasons, yeah.
- Six or seven seasons.
Definitely number
one at some point.
ABC, I remember eight
o'clock, Kirk Cameron,
""Growing Pains."
- Were you watching
as a little kid?
I mean, be honest, did you
stay up late and watch?
- I was not only
watching as a little kid,
but I did my research.
So the show came out in '85,
I was about eight,
nine years old,
and there was a belief
in my high school,
I grew up in Syosset
in Long Island,
and we knew that "Growing Pains"
took place in Long Island.
There was a rumor, it
took place in Syosset,
but we discussed this once
when I met you off-camera.
You actually told me it
took place one town over.
Is that correct?
- It took place in
Huntington, Long Island.
- One town over,
one town over.
- One town over on a street
called Robin Hood Lane.
I don't know if
that's a real street.
- We had a Robbins Lane.
We had a Robbins
Lane where I grew up.
- Okay, well that
was in Syosset.
Maybe in Huntington,
it was Robin Hood Lane.
I don't know.
- Well, anyway, you were
on a show that, to me,
like sort of just captured
what my childhood was like.
And, you know, you're a
couple of years older than me,
but we were basically
the same age.
My demeanor was very much
the demeanor of Mike Seaver
on that show, kind
of happy go lucky,
sort of popular or
whatever, that whole thing.
You were a star at
a pretty young age.
What was that like?
- Well, you know,
when I look back,
I have kids now, so
I have six children,
and I look back
and I think, man,
I would never want them
to be in the environment
that I was in, just
because it's so precarious.
It's so dangerous.
I mean, how many child TV
stars do you see that grow up,
and they turn out with their
head on their shoulders,
and, you know, where they're
not in jail, or they're not,
you know, just jumping off
some crazy cliff in some way?
And I think, wow, for me,
it was my only normal.
I can't compare it to
a different childhood.
And fortunately, I had
good people around me,
but yeah, it was very strange
at 14 years old, people
asking me for my autograph.
I thought, are you kidding?
This is some kind of a joke.
But then it went on and on,
and, you know, it was
a crazy adventure,
but one that was beautiful,
I'm thankful, I met my wife,
I got to work on projects
that I'm passionate about
all because of "Growing Pains."
And I just want to be a good
steward of these opportunities
in the platform now,
rather than just taking
advantage and, you know,
looking out for me.
- So you met your wife, Chelsea,
29 years ago on the set?
Is that right, on the set?
- We're going to celebrate
30 years this year.
So I married Mike
Seaver's girlfriend.
So you may remember
that beautiful brunette
who showed up on the
set because I sure do,
and interestingly, I
actually met her first
on my sister, Candice
Cameron's, show "Full House."
And a year later, she showed
up as Mike Seaver's girlfriend,
and then I stole her
away from Mike Seaver
behind the scenes,
and I married her,
and we're going to be
celebrating 40 years this year.
- That's hilarious.
You stole her from Mike
Seaver, who you also were.
That's very deep.
- He didn't deserve her.
Not at all.
No, no, no.
- He was a goof ball, that guy.
- Yeah, he always saw
too many fish in the sea.
He was playing in the field.
I was like, no.
I'm a one-woman guy.
So I moved in, and I
managed to make her laugh
the first time I
kissed her on screen,
and that was way ahead of
our real life relationship.
In the show, I actually
had to kiss her.
Mike Seaver had to kiss
her, and I made her laugh.
I think that was the
charm that set the hook,
and now she's mine.
- And here we are.
And you guys did all
the serious stuff.
You know, the eighties had
their melancholy episodes.
There was the episode
where you and your friends
went to that party, and a
bunch of them did cocaine,
but Mike did not.
And you've grown up to be-
- Say no to blow.
- Yeah.
(Dave chuckling)
- That's what it was.
- And you've grown up
to be a good family man.
Six freaking kids, that's nuts.
- Well, it is.
You know, unless
you're the Duggars,
then that's just light work.
But it's been, you
know, it's kind of like
the "Brady Bunch."
I don't have Alice the
maid or Sam the butcher,
but we got a house full of kids.
It's been awesome.
They're grown now.
So my kids are now 23,
22, 21, 20, 19 and 18.
And so I've got
proposals and marriages.
I've got college
and graduations.
And so we're just
kind of dealing with
the gamut of it right now.
And it's always a
growing experience,
not just for them,
but for us as parents.
- Are you saying there are
growing pains involved, Kirk?
- I am, I am.
But I wanted you
to say it, not me.
(both chuckling)
So thank you.
- So talk to me a
little bit about
the show ends, and
then eventually you
kind of reappeared,
and you started talking
more about faith
and the things that
mattered to you.
And then the media was kind of
not that nice about it, right?
Or did that take a
little while at first?
- It was good.
You know what?
It was good fodder
for the tabloid shows.
It was good ratings stuff.
But in reality, what happened
was I was an atheist.
I was one of many people
who just, you know,
never really thought about
God, never thought about faith.
I had more faith in
myself, you know,
or people that I looked up to.
And then one day, a pretty
young girl invited me
to meet her family and
they went to church.
And so I was an atheist,
and so I wasn't
interested in the church,
I was interested in the girl.
But I figured if I was ever
going to see her again,
I couldn't tell them
what I really believed.
But at the end of that day,
I was really intrigued,
and I was captured by
the message that I heard.
And I began investigating,
and eventually came to
the conclusion that maybe
this isn't all an accident,
and maybe I don't
know everything,
and eventually became persuaded
that the message of the Gospel
and the message in the Bible
was one that I wanted to
embrace with all of my heart.
And I began going that way,
and it really changed my
trajectory, not only personally,
but I wanted my personal
beliefs and convictions,
which I felt were were right,
to line up with the things
I did professionally
because I knew it would
influence other people.
You know, kind of like
what I think you're doing
a beautiful job of
taking the values
that mean something to you
and helping to spread them
because you want to produce,
you know, human flourishing.
You don't want to squash
that with bad ideas,
but up uplift it and
help it with good ideas.
- Were you surprised when you
started talking about that
and doing some other shows and
doing some stuff on your own?
And I assume you probably,
your agents must've been like,
"Oh no, he's going in this road.
He's going down this road.
This ain't gonna fly."
- Yeah.
Yeah, that kind of stuff
did start to happen.
And, you know, really
it was, I mean, imagine,
I'm 17, imagine you,
David, you're 17 years old,
you're on a TV show.
I would rather be playing
basketball with my friends,
but I got a huge
responsibility and kind of like
whatever I do affects
all these other people
and their livelihood.
And I'm feeling like, "Hey,
I think some of these jokes
for this family show in the
eighties is really kind of
maybe sending kids
down the wrong road."
And so I would request
for a line change.
Well, that could be seen
as flexing celebrity muscle
from a 17 year old kid
who thinks he's all that
when really, all I
wanted to do was be able
to go to sleep at night
with a clear conscience.
And so people
started to get upset,
and then all kinds of, you know,
E! Entertainment crazy
stories were coming out.
You know, "Kirk
Cameron born again,"
"Kirk Cameron tanks the
show," "Has actress fired."
When in reality, that
wasn't it at all.
And, you know, I look
back on "Growing Pains,"
and I say there were ups and
downs, there was challenges,
but ultimately, that's
where I found out
who my true friends are,
and that's where my faith in
God was actually strengthened
because it really caused
me to examine the things
that I hold dear and make
sure that they're tested
and that they're true.
- So as a guy that
grew up as a kid
and as an atheist, I
suppose, on television,
then you have your
kind of awakening,
does it surprise you
that Hollywood is
kind of where it's at
at the moment, which I'm sure
most of my viewers will agree
is not a great place?
- Does it surprise me?
Well, you know,
I guess I don't know whether
it surprises me or not.
One of the things that
I find interesting
is that when people are afraid
of public shame or
humiliation or condemnation,
we don't like that, right,
and so we tend to like hide,
and we don't let
people see who we are
or really what we believe.
And I think unfortunately,
people within the
family of faith
have felt that way and sort of
kept that stuff under wraps,
even though the world is
increasingly religious.
I believe that were
actually designed to know
and to love God, and so we
wind up worshiping something
if it's not God.
Whether it's yourself,
or it's the government,
or it's a group of people
you think are smarter,
But ultimately from that
source will come our laws,
and it will dictate our morality
and all of that kind of thing.
I hope that people of
faith will begin to
not divorce that faith from
the arts and entertainment.
I hope that they'll take
their faith and their values
and let it permeate the things
that will then
shape the culture.
And I think when we see more
and more faith-based movies
doing better and better
at the box office,
you look at "The Chosen," and
you see how well that's doing.
You look at the quality of that.
You look at "The Passion
of the Christ" years ago,
And even the movie
that I just finished.
I think that people are
beginning to say, like,
Wait a minute.
There's not only
a market for this,
but this is actually
communicating good messages,"
that most of us, I
believe in America,
understand we're
getting away from,
and we want to get
back to those things.
So I'm hoping for a
revival, not just, you know,
in the heart of people of faith,
but in Hollywood and
in government and
in the marketplace
and everywhere else.
- Are you hopeful Just
because of how crazy
the last year and a half was?
I've sort of come around to that
that I think so many
people, you know,
yeah, people are
depressed, they're angry,
they're confused,
all of that stuff,
but it caused them to look at
their lives more seriously,
and so I'm hopeful for that.
- Yeah, I think you're right.
And I think that they've, at
the end of the day, you know,
if you and I jump
off a building,
we don't break the
law of gravity;
the law of gravity breaks us.
There are things that
are built into the world
that are non-negotiables.
And I think that false systems
will always end up failing.
They may flourish for a
while, but it's kind of like
that big tree that you
see in the background.
Sometimes, you know,
these Oak trees get so big
and top heavy with all their
big, impressive branches,
but if the root system
underneath is not as developed,
if it's not down deep, all
it takes is a strong wind,
and the thing topples itself
'úcause it's way too top heavy.
And I think our culture
is getting that way.
Eventually it will
teeter and topple over
because our foundational
roots of faith and morality
and virtue that
our founders said
were absolutely essential
for a free society
have begun to rot and
we've neglected them.
So if we see rotten fruit,
culturally, I think
that the real answer
is a systemic answer,
and we need to go down,
and we need to begin to re
nourish the roots again.
- So you're sort of
answering my next question,
but how does the faith part-
- I knew that.
- That was pretty good,
what you did there.
How does the faith part get
you to that flag behind you
and sort of shape what
you believe politically?
- Yeah, well, I've never,
I'm really not a political guy.
I'm a family guy.
I would say I'm a faith guy.
But I have kids in the
world, and I think to myself,
what's the place going
to be like in 20 years?
That's a terrifying question
when I think about where
we're headed right now
politically, economically,
morally spiritually.
That's why I'm glad
for your program.
I'm glad for many others who
are communicating this message.
And so what I did is I said,
"You know what?
Guys like George Washington,
people like Abraham Lincoln,
and the pilgrims even
said that faith and morality
are absolute essential
for a free and just society."
And so I began researching
and educating myself,
and I found that the people
who built this country
did something that
we're not doing anymore,
and that is they're making
these sacred promises
with one another to
covenant together.
It's not just a legal contract
that we can show to a judge
later when somebody screws up
and, you know,
breaks the contract.
But it's this sense that
'til death do us part,
we are going to have
each other's back,
and we're going to do the
right thing from the heart,
and we're going to
promise with God as well
that if he would protect
us, if he would guide us,
that we trust and believe
that things will go well.
And our forefathers did that,
our foremothers understood that.
It's what they
taught to their kids.
And I believe that we
need to go back to that
if we want to see
America flourish
as a free and just society.
Even economically,
even educationally,
all of these things, I think
are our fruit on the tree
with the roots going down
into faith and virtue.
And that's what I'm trying
to get people to think about,
hoping that we, the
people of America,
will come up with a solution
and not wait for our hope
to fly in on Air Force One.
- It ain't coming.
Not from any Air Force One,
but particularly not from the
guy on this Air Force One.
Which one of your
sons did I meet?
How old was he?
- So that's James,
and James is 18,
and he actually took his
last math final today
and graduated high school.
- Wow.
- Very exciting day.
- Do I say
congratulations to you?
I guess so.
You're the dad, you got...
- Yeah, thanks.
Thanks, yeah.
- Tell James I said
congratulations.
But the reason I bring him up
is because I met you
at an event in Florida.
A bunch of his friends
were around there,
and you were saying,
"Oh, Dave, you know,
you've affected these kids."
And I love hearing
that because it's like,
oh, that means that
there are young people
who are thinking about freedom,
thinking about all the
things that I talk about.
Are you hopeful,
like when you talk to
your kids of those ages,
who are going to be the ones
that get us out of this mess,
like, are you hopeful
that they can do it?
- Yeah, I am hopeful
that they can do it.
It's always young
people that have,
that they're frontal...
Well, A, they have all of this
energy, all of this passion,
and they want to change
the world, right?
I mean, you talk
about young people
and always talking about
they want cultural change,
they want a revolution,
and they want to be part
of something bigger
than themselves.
A lot of the older
folks, I'm 50 now,
we have gray hair, which
is a sign of wisdom.
We've been around a while to see
that all this history stuff
is actually important.
And so when you're
young, you need a vision.
And so I think that
if we give the vision
as older wiser people
who understand that
ideas have consequences,
that history can teach us about
where we're headed
in the future,
that if they get
on board with that
and they're inspired,
if they catch the vision that's
rooted in the right stuff,
I think that that not only,
I don't think that it's they
who are going to
make the difference,
I'm banking on the power of
God working in their hearts
and through their minds
to make better decisions
than we've made in
this generation.
That's where my hope is.
- What have you done, you
and your wife, I guess,
to make sure your
kids are not infected
by so much of what's
going on out there
with critical race
theory, identity politics,
just all the cultural norms?
Because I get a ton of
questions about that
from people that are of
our old age, 45 and 50,
that are like, "What do
I do about the kids?"
- Yeah.
Well, that's a great question,
and I don't have the,
I don't know, that I have a
one size fits all fix for that,
but, you know. we homeschooled
our kids for many years,
and we didn't do that
because we were running
away from something.
We felt we could offer our kids
a superior educational path
by teaching them the values
and giving them the
sources of information
and history about,
and government and
literature and faith
that they weren't going to
get at a regular school.
And then some of the
years were actually spent
at private schools as well.
But this stuff that you're
talking about is pervasive.
And so, you know, honestly,
I invite friends, my kids'
friends and my friends,
to sit around a
campfire like this,
and to say, "Hey what do
you think of that flag?"
You know, "What is
important to you?"
"What are you kids,
what are your friends
dealing with right now,
you know, in relationships,
politically?"
You know, "What are
the taboo things
that you can and cannot say?"
And then we discuss
those things.
I think not just
swallowing the narrative
that's coming in off of
your social media feed,
but researching things,
and that's even becoming
increasingly difficult, right?
Because stuff's getting
scrubbed off the internet
and filtered out
to where, you know,
I can't even say
certain words right now.
You and I I might get
this video scrubbed.
And so maybe you
found a workaround,
but it's challenging.
- Well, yeah, last
week, I had to edit
for the first time ever in
all my years of doing a show.
- Really?
- We had David Horowitz on.
He said something
that he believed
as a free person in a
somewhat free society.
But we knew that if
we aired it as is,
we were going to get,
we were in risk of getting
our channel booted.
For the first time ever,
I had to edit something,
or we put soundbars
over it on YouTube.
Put it on my Locals
channel, though.
- Yeah.
Well, that's great.
And you know what I hope Dave
is I hope that we realize like,
you know, that we're all sort
of kicking ourselves now,
going, "Wait a
minute, wait a minute.
Why did we think of creating
our own social media channels
and news outlets and
keeping those free?
Why don't we think of
that 40 years ago?"
You know, but the good
news, I think now,
is we're waking up to it,
and now these things are
beginning to be formed,
and now we're beginning
to be able to, you know,
not rely on other
people who disagree
and want to squash our message
to distribute and
promote our message.
That just doesn't make sense,
but, you know, it was
easy, it was free,
and so we just kinda
went along with it.
So I'm hopeful that we are
at a very exciting point
in history and that
people are gonna look back
on this generation and say
there were a few people they
may have been, you know,
out funded and outnumbered,
but they did the right thing
and Heaven was behind them,
and they made the difference.
- That guy, David,
beat Goliath, right?
Am I getting that story correct?
- He did.
But you know, he
was a little guy,
and David was a really big guy.
And I think the lesson
there is that, you know,
the only way that that
story ever makes sense
is when God is working through
David to defeat Goliath.
And that's my hope is that
he'll also work through us
to take down the
nefarious forces
that would love to
see freedom go away.
- So for the people
that have not seen
the "Campfire Revival,"
you are sitting at the
campfire right now.
You lit the fire for us.
Hopefully you're not
going to self-immolate
or burn the flag
while we're here.
But you did this all
just as we sat down.
What are you doing over there
at the "Campfire Revival"
on Instagram and Facebook?
Is that it, just chat?
Well, I know what you're doing.
So I'm asking you,
I'm asking as the
audience, not as myself.
I know what you're doing.
- Okay, so basically,
this all started,
you know, after this
whole last year,
and then through the election
time and then the inauguration
and people are talking
about the first hundred days
of the administration,
and, you know, so many
of us have been sort of
like waiting and hoping for
someone else to do something,
and we're waiting
for this to happen.
And I thought to myself, as
I'm sitting in my backyard
cooped up in the California,
where you're basically
under house arrest
and lockdown at the time,
"Wait a minute, what's our plan?
What kind of a hundred day
plan could I be a part of
that's going to actually
promote the positive change
rather than just
complaining about the things
that I don't like to see?"
And I said, "You know what?
I don't know the best plan,
but I'm going to start a
plan, and it's going to be,
I'm going to sit in my
backyard for 100 days in a row
and build a campfire."
And I'm going to invite
other people to join me
as we pray, as we worship God,
and as we begin to
learn what made America
the freest, strongest, most
prosperous nation in the world.
And we found that
on Facebook Live,
we'd have 15 to 20,000 people
every single night joining,
and the comments were flying,
and people made it a
destination every night
because they found hope
and they found something
for them to talk
about with their kids.
And we did that for 100 days,
called it the "American
Campfire Revival."
And it's all about that
inside out strategy,
that bottom up strategy
that our founders understood
and that I think is
going to be the solution
to getting us back to
where we want to go.
- Yeah.
What else are you
working on right now?
Are you going to
be traveling again
and spreading the word
and getting out there?
I mean, you're hear in Cali,
where we are opening up
apparently at some point.
- Yeah, that's right.
Well, I am working on
quite a few things.
This "American Campfire
Revival" has been
just kind of a surprise
joy for me to do.
Although, all of my
wardrobe smells like smoke
and my wife is kind
of tired of it.
I'm roasting like a
marshmallow as we speak.
My backside is
turning golden brown.
You just can't see it.
- [Dave] Nice, nice.
- And we're going
to continue this,
and I'm about to
start another 40 days
of the "American
Campfire Revival,"
speaking about family covenants
and then community
covenants, church covenants,
and civil government covenants,
that kind of all
weave together to form
kind of this this Kevlar fabric
that I believe will resist
the darts of tyranny
and totalitarianism.
In fact, this is something
I wanted to show you.
This is a pledge that
I kind of modeled
after the "Declaration
of Independence,"
called, "Our Pledge to Renew
the American Covenant."
And it's what we can
affirm together as families
and as individuals to
get back to these values,
and we've signed it here,
and I'm hoping people
will hang us in their wall
and talk about it as a family
and with their neighbors.
And then we have some live
events around the country
where we gather in
fields and farms...
(loud popping noise)
- Oh, whoa.
You didn't just...
- No, that's alright.
We're good.
- But if you dropped
the whole covenant
in the fire just
then, that woulda'...
- Here it is.
And we're still good.
And gather around
bonfires and sing and pray
and talk about what
really matters,
and if we have one
here in California,
I'll make sure
that I invite you.
I'd love to have you come.
- I'd love to come.
For a second, I thought
Newsome was about to try
to take you out.
I thought he had, you know,
'cause he's got these
snipers out there.
People are in the
backyard having fun
with an American flag, jeez.
- That's actually the
first time that's happened.
So I think, if you see any
smoke coming from behind me,
you let me know, okay?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I hope you have
insurance for this program.
Wait, so give me some of the,
give me two or three
of the, not edicts,
of the principles that
are on the document there.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah
- That's it.
Let's see.
Boy, here we go.
We promise to each
other as a family
to provide for one
another as long as we live
as commanded in scripture.
There's so many others.
We commit to living peacefully,
to obeying the laws of the land
and working to elect
godly, trustworthy leaders
who will not abuse
their limited power
as our public servants and
distort our constitution.
So we talk about the civic
realm and also the family realm
and also the community realm.
And, you know, all
of it really begins
with self-government, right?
I think this is important.
I think people would
find this interesting.
When we talk about government,
we're usually
talking about them,
you know, like out
there or up there,
we're talking about
the government and
what they're doing,
but in our country,
our founders understood
that that kind of
government will be terrible
totalitarian government unless
we lay the foundation
of self-government.
And if we govern
ourselves according to the
the rules of right, right,
like, it's not
about left or right.
It's about up or down.
And if we go up to
Heaven's rules of right,
then we don't need the
government with the big stick
to beat us back into civility.
We've already got that.
We got that individually.
We got it in our families.
We got it in our communities,
and government can
stay limited and small
and people have freedom.
And so that's
really the essence.
The most powerful culture
transforming force in the world
is the self-governing person
who loves God and
loves their neighbor.
That's what our
founders believed,
and that's what I'm trying
to communicate to people.
- Which one do you
think is harder
for your old Hollywood
friends to swallow:
the belief part or your
feelings about government part?
Because they probably
not thrilled with either.
(Kirk laughing)
- You mean government
being limited?
- Yeah, well, that you
believe in small government
and the constitution, that
America is good, you know,
that sort of stuff,
or the belief part, is that
harder for them to swallow?
- Oh boy.
I dunno.
You know, it's all
so tied together.
But actually, I think that
it's interesting you said
that small government
and that America is good.
You know, the principles...
- [Dave] Radical stuff, I know.
- Is founded on are
absolutely good.
The framework is genius.
It's beautiful, but it depends
on personal self-government.
All of our founders
told us that,
and the truth is I'm
actually for big government,
but it's not what you think.
It's big self-government.
It's big family government.
And once we take care of that,
we don't need a big police force
because we're doing
the right thing
at the friend and family level.
- I think a lot of people
are watching this going,
"What are you two fools
still doing in California?"
I mean, at this point for
you, is it just the weather?
I mean, you could be
doing this in Florida
or Texas or Tennessee.
- Yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
And I certainly understand
why people are moving
out of here.
They're getting out of here
like rats jumping off of a ship
because we're sinking
economically and politically;
however, I'm all about revival.
Look at my shirt, "American
Campfire Revival."
Revival, right?
So that means, like, putting
life back into things again.
Things that are flat-lining
and dying, reviving them.
I think that can
happen anywhere.
I think it can happen
in my marriage,
if my marriage is flat-lining.
I think it can happen in
my family, my community.
I think it can
happen in our state.
And so I'm hoping and
praying that America
and starting with California
begins to see a a renewal,
a revival, and a resurgence
of the kind of stuff
that will cause human
flourishing, not human decay.
- What do you think we can
do in this crazy state?
I mean, you know, I'm
hanging on by a thread, man.
- I know.
I hear you.
I'm here.
Well, I'm starting
with a campfire.
- Alright, alright.
Fair enough.
Alright, that's it.
I'm coming to the campfire.
- And I'm listening to you,
and I'm listening to others,
and I believe that
there are people
with more brilliant
ideas than I have
that are going to help move
us in the right direction.
And I continue to pray for them.
- Do you find that people
across the country,
when you're traveling,
regardless of whether
you're red or blue
or any of that stuff, that
people are pretty much the same?
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
What's going on behind you now?
- That people are
pretty much the same.
What do you mean?
Like, regardless of whether
they're red or blue?
- That if you can
really get to them,
that the stuff that
you're talking about
is sort of the stuff
that they really believe,
some of them just
don't know it maybe.
- You know, I think
that people want it.
People want it.
They want to have a good job.
They want to be able to
put food on their table
and provide for their family.
They want to have
a sense of purpose
like their life
counts for something.
And I think people have
been sold different recipes
on how they're
going to get that.
And so, you know, politically,
you know, are you
going to have somebody
who's going to give
you those things
or give you the opportunity
to work for those things
and invest in those things?
That's one aspect of it.
But I think at the
end of the day,
if we're talking about
values, you know,
I've got friends who are on
the other side of the aisle,
and, you know, they want
the same things that I want.
I want an opportunity to
provide for my family.
be able to speak the truth
and not be censored for it.
I want an opportunity
to pursue happiness
and not be restricted
and controlled and
thrown into a cage
because somebody
disagrees with me.
And I think there's a very
specific way to go about that,
and that's what I'm
trying to promote.
- Yeah.
When you get those
guys on the other side
of the aisle to come
to the campfire,
are they able to do it?
'Cause that's what a
lot of my, let's say,
conservative friends
are now struggling with.
It's like, "Yeah, I'll have
that conversation with anybody,"
but they don't seem to want
to have that
conversation with us.
- Yeah.
I do know what
you're talking about.
I hope I'm not just, you know,
parroting something here.
I think I really do see
some groups of people
really going after
facts and data and statistics,
and I see other groups of people
that seem to not want to
talk about those things,
but really pour on the
lighter fluid of emotion
and sometimes not
deal with the issues.
I'm all about dealing
with the issues
and understanding
what the facts are,
and then let's work
together to solve problems.
You know, I've got a family too,
and I've got neighbors too,
and rather than the
government taking my money
to give to other people
in an inefficient way,
I would rather keep my money
and have a heart of compassion
that gets to know my
neighbor and help them out
at the local level.
I just think that's
more efficient.
I think that's better, and
it develops relationships
that cause communities
to flourish.
- Where am I sending
the fine people?
Just to kirkcameron.com?
Because if I send them
to Facebook, I mean,
you could say something and
next thing you know, long gun.
- Yeah.
So, you know, yeah, just
send them to my website,
kirkcamero.com.
We've got all the info there.
You can check out the
"American Campfire Revival"
and stay in touch.
- Kirk, I'm coming
over for a campfire.
- Come on.
- You're doing the s'mores?
You're doing the s'mores?
- I'm doing the s'mores.
You know, if you got something
that you want to
grill on the fire,
you just bring it with you.
- You've seen some of
the things I'm grilling.
I'll bring over the meat.
And you've got like a crazy
flame thrower over there,
don't you?
- I do.
This guy gave it to me.
It's like a personal
flame thrower.
Like, like every guy needs one.
Especially if you have a beard,
this is a tool you need
to have in your toolbox.
It throws out about a
five, six foot flame,
and it's awesome.
- I will bring the meat.
You bring the flame thrower.
Keep the American
flag right there.
Will be a hell of an evening.
- Let's do it.
- We will put it on
Instagram or something.
- Let's do it.
- Alright, Kirk Cameron,
great seeing you, man.
- Thanks, you too.
Take care, Dave.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist, all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.